[Musique]
moi l'eau
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour la
famille doit part en vacances on produit
quand même ton soir on a le temps est là
mais vous oubliez créé deux chiens n'ont
pas être mal vie complet le plat par
dante office sacré tonte ans boivent
créé et de chiens pour profite pour se
dégourdir les pattes mais ma parole
ton doigt le fait extraits il est encore
parti en oubliant credo chien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour toi allez viens avec moi
[Musique]
on crée deux chiens chic tantôt on voit
un petit creux à on va pouvoir s'arrêter
pour pique [ __ ] 29 pas ton doigt il
l'a pas fait exprès dongeois joue
maintenant avec le credo chiens non non
moi tout va tout et nous nous avons bien
compris ton 11 mois essaye de faire
perdre le pauvre créé deux chiens
[Musique]
vous connaissez l'histoire du petit
poucet
[Musique]
à
pauvre gré de chiens douala perdu dans
la forêt
[Musique]
et nous on ne pleure pas créé de chiens
c'est une idée de watou à tout pour te
ramener à la voiture
[Musique]
enfin maintenant par mois et oui plus de
credo chien le von ah revoilà créé deux
chiens quant aux colères tout endroit au
nom était bien puisque c'est comme ça en
employant les grands moyens
[Musique]
et voilà c'est gagné elisabeth pique une
colère mais nous colère n'a plus son
crâne de chien elle ne veut plus bouger
il n'y a rien à faire et au tournoi n'a
plus qu'à retourner à pied à l'endroit
où il a ajouté que red hot chili
[Musique]
pendant que tonton voies contournent la
colline nous nous allons prendre un
raccourci maintenant c'est au tour de
canton doivent être abandonné si bien
merci voit tout bateau elisabeth enfance
et leur maman passe après midi au square
[Musique]
ça y est ça ne lave pas soit le fond tu
commences attaquer les cris des chiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant tient tranquille
[Musique]
tiens un credo anne tenté t il est
mignon qu'est ce qu'il fait mais ils
l'attachent à la pelote de laine de
maman à tours et au regard
tout
ayvaz la hêtraie de chiens tirs sur
notre but maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez c'est la statue du général
tiens quelle famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car tu dois préparer une bêtise bon
maintenant ça s'essouffle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est vraiment insupportable ce gamin
bombe à froid ça va te calmer maintenant
ne te plains pas sur les animaux se
venge toutes les misères que tu leur as
fait ciblées
[Musique]
bon cette fois écouté voit tout et tout
ne soyez pas méchant avec les animaux
[Musique]
sont gentils dans cette famille mais un
peu fourre sont rendu compte aux frais
des grains à watou et on allait souvenez
vous soyez gentil avec eux à minuit
d'accord au revoir tous la barbe fou de
forêt vierge africaine les animaux
sauvages des disques encore en liberté
[Musique]
alerte de chasseurs cachez-vous ses
débuts un credo lyon
cache toi mais cache toi vite et chasse
avant de voir
[Musique]
c'est raté
ce que vous faites mais lâché le et ne
vous a rien fait on voterait l'oignon
moi tu vois tu entends il ya un créneau
lyon qui pleure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention ils ont des armes
[Musique]
à
oh
voyons parmi les animaux que l'on ne
chasse pas avec un fusil ils ignorent
je suis sous les moustiques à la bac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui vois toi ton tu as raison le
safari photo c'est bien plus amusant que
de chasser avec un fusil et regardez le
credo lyon vous fait en prime des
sourires
[Musique]
mais voilà c'est pas plus sympathique
comme ça allez au revoir les chasseurs
il fait de belles photos merci à tous à
tous
[Musique]
au coeur d'une grande et belle forêt une
gentille famille de crédin sauvage et
lille est en paix qu'est ce que c'est
des sous à casqués armés de seuil et de
haches montesson des bulldozer attaque
la forêt
[Musique]
abattent des arts
pour faire place à une autoroute
[Musique]
adoré la famille de crédits sauvage
d'état là toutes les têtes
mais de quel côté qu'ils aillent des
machines terrifiante se dresse devant
eux
[Musique]
allez allez un petit effort
ouf
il s'en est fallu de peu
mais hélas il est trop tard les machines
barre la route
et le petit credo se trouve désormais
séparé de sa famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de l'autre côté de l'autoroute
la maman credo il désespérer
[Musique]
ça y est l'autoroute est terminée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et petit matou bateau se transforme en
pompe les ouvriers n'arriverons à rien
et pensons d'un bois très résistant
[Rires]
heureusement tout finit bien
rabattus par les ouvriers le petit
radeau se dirige vers l'autoroute
tu peux maintenant traverser grâce au
pont et voici la famille de crédits
sauvage de nouveau réunis au revoir à
tous à tous et merci
oui
il fait beau cet après midi hier la
campagne un petit credo lapin deuxième
petit cri de l'apa et voici le troisième
petit creux de la main
non loin de là dans sa maison un
chasseur se prépare voulait cependant
les petits cris de la tamise attention
voilà quelqu'un soit le fons et papa
soit approche
[Musique]
fatiguant l'achat et c'est beaucoup plus
amusant de monter sur le dos de son papa
allez on a beau aimer où ils sont
dangereux tous les deux ils vont signer
par blesser quelqu'un
[Musique]
mais oui commençons par mettre les
craies de latin à l'abri et maintenant
les chasseurs vont avoir une drôle de
surprise
dis papa ça existe et lapins rouge
[Musique]
habas a décrit deux lapins qui volent
mais ce n'est pas possible bien sûr des
défend de tout de suite
oh c'est pas parce voix qui descend
[Musique]
c'est fini les cris de l'apa ne risque
plus rien
[Musique]
et les chasseurs ont compris
en tout cas il nous aurons bien fait
rire
merci à tous à tout a bien été
[Musique]
c'est une adorable petite rivière qui
court à travers les champs bonjour à
tous à tous bonjour décret de moutons
bonjour très beau papillon
tiens voilà david c'est tonton zoua zoua
le fons en grande tenue de pêcheurs sur
l'enfant tu vas faire fuir les poissons
[Musique]
on accroche un soin stick haut à
l'hameçon oui évidemment aux alphonse
manque encore un peu d'entraînement
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça y'est sa mort non ça ne mord pas sa
belle
c'est un credo moutons à 10 mai
[Musique]
super quand on vous a fait du ski
nautique france qui encore mieux du ski
nautique sans eau
[Musique]
revenons à nos moutons je dire à notre
pêche et qu'est ce qu'ils font il ne
faut pas jeter pierres mais ils vont
qu'à fuir les poissons coucher sales
bêtes
enfin
pourtant on voit avec toutes ces misères
il n'a encore rien pêcher et des normes
en costaud c'est astique on retrouve
dans l'eau ça commence à bien faire
[Musique]
il écoute le petit dostie qu il se porte
on doit ces gens qui ont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et voilà nos deux pêcheurs vente par la
maison mouillé et brebis accompagné par
un troupeau de credo moutons par
atlantico au revoir à tous à tous la
famille noah est en pique nique ça y est
on doit bien oui un essaim du credo
abeilles
attention c'est dangereux non info
en attendant on essaye de faire tomber
les saints d'abel cachés par des
feuilles c'est imprudent temps on voit
voilà je te l'avais dit un petit bisou
au deuxième petit bisou déjà privés de
leurs essaims les crédos au bypass à
l'attack attention
[Musique]
par contre là sort une bombe à ce qui
aiguise ses membres
[Musique]
les petits bateaux apportent des fleurs
pour les crédos abeilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
regardez comme un conte
[Musique]
ce qu'ils vont en boîte au maintien
oh
un peu de fumée pour endormir les
créneaux horaires on récupère la mienne
ni parti ni
et déguster au
travaillent et créent des abeilles merci
autour et au revoir
regardez moi ces trois commerces
apparemment elles ont des choses très
importantes à dire quel bar à regarder
[Musique]
en
m
c'était exactement ce qu'il nous faut
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames vos jambes et à élever
des poules bonjour monsieur il nous
faudrait trois toques de fourrure ou
trois toques de fourrure atteint
d'amendé il ne me reste qu'une une seule
quelle horreur ne bougez pas nous j'ai
pas je vais me renseigner
[Musique]
allo l'alaska 1 à l'oscar
ouais ouais ouais ouais c'est très grave
à désirer il me faut de la fourrure
plein de fourrure tout plein de fouet
heureusement on tend cette conversation
téléphonique eh bien les chasseurs vont
partir chercher des petits geeks
elle a heureusement watou à tout est là
mais que prépare t-il encore
qu'est ce que tu vois toi tous racontent
ce que distillent au j'aimerais bien
savoir
attention les chasseurs arrive c'est
l'échangé pensent à leur dur travail
c'est pour moi des petits couacs ont
l'air tout gentil tout calme
[Musique]
pourquoi voit tour à tour i comme ça que
se passe-t-il
ils inventer encore mes remarques et les
sacs fonde mais pourquoi et chasseurs
rappel le joueur nous avons ce qu'il
vous faut
pl de fourrure mais il m'en faut encore
plus beaucoup plus encore
bon bah nous allons trouver beaucoup
plus les chasseurs par regarder ce qu'on
fait les boîtes aux lettres
il cache les vrais bébés phoques ils
prennent des petits ou de glace à la
place des blocs même et il façonne des
bébés phoques
ils feignent la glace regardez
exactement quel sculpteur et voilà
comment on fait un fonds d'aidé folle on
line en place
et le tour est joué
les chasseurs arrive le sol ne savons
rien c'était bien vite tous les bébés
phoques sont à l'abri
regardez moi ces trois niveaux une voie
rien et continuent leur horrible travail
et bien sûr à tout bateau de rire et les
salles de fondre aof
cl ça va
inconscient les chasseurs s'en
retournent ils vont même jusqu en vivre
j'ai regardé les sacs à main et
épouvantable ils réduisent de taille
un fois ravi vous m'apportez des
fourrures c'est merveilleux
félicitations messieurs
oui regardez des blocs de glace à moitié
fondue sortent des sacs
j'imaginais la colla de fourrure rousse
colère très très grosse colère il
poursuit les chasseurs
[Musique]
jusqu'à 100 la banquise et regarder les
bébés forme de rire les ouates aussi et
la belle punition bien méritée par ses
offres chasseurs aller plus fort et
encore
enfin
[Musique]
vont-ils tous chez le fourreur au regard
des malins comme il est le foreur vend
maintenant dès qu'ils faisaient de la
part des faits il a ouvert un café c'est
mieux comme ça non merci à toutes et à
tous et bravo au revoir les des phoques
[Musique]
en macho intervenez les enfants je vais
vous montrer quelque chose ça c'est une
centrale hydroélectrique l'eau qui
s'écoule à travers le barrage fait
tourner les turbines qui produisent de
l'électricité
c'était le cul souper est ensuite
conduite par des fils électriques et ce
jusqu'à la maison où nous en profitons
mais l'électricité d'une invention
moderne à l'âge de pierre tout ça
n'hésitez pas vous pensez on venait
juste de découvrir le feu
soit plus tard au temps de nos ancêtres
les gaulois
il y avait la langue kabyle voit un peu
plus tard encore dans les châteaux du
moyen âge on s'éclairait à la bougie on
se servait de la bougie dans les
campagnes je les nourris à la sève
ah oui toi sois plus près de nous dans
le château du roi soleil y avait un
valet spécialement chargé d'éteindre
toutes sont belles à l'essieu quel
boulot fait pas chaud à nouveau les fans
de retrouver cette époque les grandes
décisions se prenaient de la lueur d'une
lanterne
[Musique]
heureusement un bon jour est savant
inventa l'électricité soit
oh mais l'électricité ça peut faire très
mal parfaitement l'électricité c'est
dangereux et je vous défends de toucher
emprise je vais faire des cours soyez
sages ont pas dit de ne pas toucher
inquiète pas je vais juste jeter un
petit coup d'oeil
[Musique]
cela prépare une grosse bêtise
voyez pas
[Musique]
couper tout occupé à langon ça ne
marchait plus remettez le courant
[Musique]
maintenant écoutez moi on ne touche pas
en prise électrique
pas besoin d'être une lumière pour
comprendre ça renvoie tout et tout
[Musique]
merci à aa
mon pauvre tu en seras tu chante comme
une casserole
avec nous
maintenant que vous connaissez la garde
on va vous apporter des instruments
[Musique]
on y va tous ensemble
cerise et les maths
[Musique]
chanter avec nous les enfants
mademoiselle m à côté de cette danse
évoqué allez suivez la partition avec
les petits bretons
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
ils vont reprenons au
ah ah pauvre ton se voient pour lui il
est inutile d'insister
[Musique]
rejoins moi toi ton et ne t'en fais pas
l' orchestre des oies est bien parti
pour faire une grande carrière
et puisque ton choix ne s'est pas
chanter il prendra la baguette
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la famille joie est en vacances à la
montagne tiens il semblerait que cette
émission est donné des idées aux enfants
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe il croit s'être équipé comme
de vrais alpinistes sans rien dire à
personne ils partent à l'assaut de la
montagne
[Musique]
et en plus il pleut
avec une corde à sauter quelle idée là
prendre entre ses dents oui mais il ne
faut pas parler
[Musique]
à toi credo chat lisabeth couche de
secours auprès de ses parts
[Musique]
mais attention je ressens tu étouffes
credo chat
[Musique]
et
rv au credo chat
[Musique]
ans
la corde sur le couteau tranchant plus
en bronze
en ce cas la prudence il était temps
[Musique]
ça y est tu en auras encore prendre la
direction des opérations
il n'est pas équipé non plus est d'abord
une icône est rien
[Musique]
voilà credo chat est sauvé tonton doit
aussi d'ailleurs
[Musique]
or
faites attention la montagne peut être
dangereux soyez prudent renvoie tout
[Musique]
star wayne rooney
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on attend la demande au greffe
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
zéro pointé aux as
madoff
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur les pêcheurs sa mort
avait coiffé stu aux joies stick ou
fines ne cède pas faire au même instant
des chasseurs bat la campagne
[Musique]
deux adorables petit credo pied j'ai
pris ma parole
il faut du tir au pigeon avec de vrais
credo pigeons
[Musique]
m
un peu plus loin des parieurs misent de
l'argent sur un combat de credo cote
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
au même moment dans une arène rempli à
craquer des toreros font leur entrée
bientôt suivi par un credo toro et son
copain le credo moustiques
et
[Musique]
on
mais le credo toro joue avec son ami
il ne se rend pas compte du danger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sonic
moi tout a tout arraché ce asticots
arrache les crédos pigeons
[Musique]
aller chasser azerty
ni ses pêchés avec des crédos pigeon
petit matou emporte les crédos cote
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps le credo thon rouge
joue toujours avec son petit copain le
credo moustique qui lui prend
tranquillement enfin tranquillement un
verre sont le nez décret de taureaux
là
elle est créée et de coop fonce dans
l'arène
[Musique]
bien fou
et voilà tout est rentré dans l'ordre le
petit asticot prend une douche les
crédos pigeons au cool dans un
pigeonnier et les crédos coque courtisé
credo pour le credo toro traque avec son
copain credo moustiques renvoi ou
alouettes
lannion
[Musique]
titre
oh
m
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et